This was our final answer. Excellent work if you found it. We start by finding
the lowest common denominator, which means that we have to factor this
denominator and this one first. Factors of 24 that sum to positive 10 are
positive 6 and positive 4, while the factors of negative 12 that sum to positive
1 are positive 4 and negative 3. This means that our lowest common denominator
would be y plus 6 times y plus 4 times y minus 3. Next, we multiply each
fraction by the missing factors of our lowest common denominator. For the first
denominator, it's missing the factor y minus 3. So we multiply the numerator and
denominator by y minus 3, since we're really just multiplying by 1. For the
second fraction, we need to multiply by y plus 6 divided by y plus 6. When we
multiply each of these fractions by a form of 1, we get two new equivalent
fractions. We multiply these two numerators together, or these two binomials
together, to get y squared minus 6y plus 9. And then here again, we multiply
these two binomials together to get y squared plus 12y plus 36. We multiply
these out, since we're adding our numerators in the end. The denominators,
however, we can just leave in factored form since these won't change. When we
add the like terms of our numerators together, we get 2y squared from 1y squared
and 1y squared. We get positive 6y, from negative 6y and positive 12y. And we
get 45 from positive 9 and positive 36. And finally, we want to check to see if
this is factorable, to see if we can cancel a factor in the numerator and
denominator. We find factors of 90 that sum to positive 6. When I look at the
positive factors of 90, these are the factor pairs. None of these add to
positive 6. So I know this numerator is not factorable. Since we cant factor
this numerator, we actually have our final answer. None of these add to positive
6.